creeps everyone I'm Alana and I'm coming
to you live from out of space
I'm not really it's a green screen but
that's what I wanted to talk to you
about today green screens are getting
incredibly popular for people who are
recording Let's Plays or doing live
streams and have been popular in the
television and online video industry for
a very long time the one that's behind
me I think is the best one I've ever
used in my five years working on camera
this one is from El Gato which is
company a lot of you probably already
know from their really great game
capture devices and I will show G guys
in more detail but I want to say out of
the gate it is incredibly easy to setup
because of the way it's setup you don't
have to worry about any kind of rippling
and while it is heavy which is probably
my biggest complaint it's also very easy
to carry and transport but anyone who
hasn't worked with the green screen
those are all the main things that you
need to worry about some of them take a
really really long time to set up
sometimes when you set them up that
totally crease so it basically ruins the
effect to talk measurements because I
know that that doesn't necessarily pick
up on camera it's 148 centimeters by 180
centimeters which is fifty eight point
twenty seven inches by seventeen point
eighty seven inch it collapses into this
little rectangle that's 148 centimeters
by 10 centimeters by 11 centimeters
which is 64 point 76 by four point one
three by four point five three interest
and that's a lot of words I think I said
interest on the end there but I had to
remember a lot of numbers so let me show
you what it looks like in practice so as
you can see it is pretty tall that's a
door frame to give you an idea of the
exact height and because of the weight
the thing that keeps it upright is this
little stand down the bottom here so to
show you guys that in action to retract
it all you have to do is push it down
you close this case with these little
clasps here that go on both sides and
then you fold the legs in on both sides
of course those are needed to actually
keep it upright and then you pick it up
and you are good to go so the setup from
start to finish is so I thought I would
show you guys what the reverse side of
this actually looks like to explain how
it works so basically it's just got
these two pots that stand out here so if
you want to pull it down it
automatically collapses them and it
doesn't really slowly - voila so
obviously this is a very awkwardly short
video because I live in a tiny studio
apartment but I just think this is so
cool and such a good thing for content
creators to use that I really wanted to
make a video about it despite my
terrible setup but even in my tiny
apartment it's not inconvenient at all
and you know what it'd be cool if I
could have a bigger apartment
much better
Thank You green-screen I believe it is
149 95 or something else that loosely
translates to $150 and as mentioned is
an elgato product as for editing it out
there are several things you can use to
do that I use Premiere Pro personally
but I think even iMovie how does it
feature to do that and there are tons
and tons of tutorials available for that
kind of thing on YouTube if you look at
how to use a green screen on how to key
out green Premiere Pro then you will get
tons and tons of walkthroughs for that
but way better than anything I could
make and that is it for me today
everyone a huge thank you to everyone
whose names are on screen right now I'm
Alana and I will see you guys next time